new figures released by the home office
show that a record number of migrants
crossed the english channel
yesterday video from today shows dozens
including children on several dinghies
without life jackets
our skies mark white is with us uh
and the numbers just keep going up don't
they mark
yes they do i mean a record close to 500
migrants crossing the channel yesterday
is of great concern i mean there are
divisions of course on this issue there
are those who
say that people should not be crossing
illegally like this into the uk
uh and it needs to be stopped others who
say
these people are desperate and they need
help
and if they claim asylum that asylum
should be granted but i think
everyone can agree that images like this
are very concerning indeed
a big inflatable there but absolutely
packed to the gunnels we counted at
least 35
individuals that we can see on there we
don't know if there's any more in the
middle section there
but you can see none of them wearing
life jackets at all just uh
two or three of them carrying these
inflatable inner tubings
but if that and it looks from the the
stringer that was
filming this for us in the middle of the
channel uh that the
the boat itself ran out of fuel the
engine
stopped its mid channel uh and waiting
to be rescued
clearly that has dangers because of the
very busy shipping lane that it's in uh
there's also
of course the very real danger of a wave
because mid-channel even on a remarkably
clear day
like today you can get waves that could
easily uh inundate
that boat that can wash people overboard
and as we saw from the images there and
no one
in that particular boat that bigger boat
wearing a live vest at all
other boats have come across where you
see they seem to be better organized
uh with everyone on board wearing life
vests but it's still very dangerous
lives have been lost
in the channel luckily thus far no very
significant
numbers of uh people have died in
incidents in the channel but
the home secretary pretty patel said she
believed it might only be a matter of
time
before there is a real tragedy and when
you're talking about numbers
uh almost uh touching 500 of people
trying to cross the channel it's clearly
an issue in terms of
what the british government is doing to
try to get on top of this
particular situation well they have
given the french authorities
more money an additional 54 million
pounds
was announced last month this came on
top of grants
the previous months to try to boost the
number of french
police and other personnel guarding
those beaches
where traditionally the uh migrants have
been
getting on board the boats and coming
across to the uk but
the issue that they have is that the
people smugglers the organized criminal
gangs are adapting their tactics they're
not using
the same old beaches they're going
further up the coast further down the
coast
even into belgium and the netherlands
it's a much greater distance
they have to cross which in itself of
course is more dangerous
but it means also for the authorities
it's far more difficult for them
to get on top of the situation and to
try to stop the boats before they take
to the water
mark thank you very much